hi everyone it is so amazing to be here
um this is my first in-person conference
and only second conference presentation
ever and it's been really amazing here
hearing a lot of these talks meeting
some amazing people and just the general
knowledge sharing that's been going on
these past few days it's been really
incredible and I'm so happy to be a part
of it
um today I'm going to be talking about a
recent project that I've been working on
it's kind of a segue into talking about
some Design Concepts of the developer
tools Spacey and Prodigy that I think
are honestly super powerful in enhancing
developer productivity for everyone from
the coding newbies to the advanced and
complicated project teams
before we start on the content I'll give
a short introduction about myself so I'm
Victoria I'm a developer advocate for
explosion as mentioned we are the makers
and maintainers of Spacey which is a
tool for natural language processing
pipelines and projects and also Prodigy
which is a scriptable annotation tool so
I've been working with explosion for
about 10 months now I started just after
I graduated University my academic
background is in purely Linguistics so
I'm a self-taught developer and it's
been super amazing learning from all the
amazing people at explosion and growing
my skills there
one of those amazing co-workers is
Vincent uh he's been working with me on
this project
he does a ton of cool stuff within
explosion and a lot of also recreational
programming as he calls it which has
resulted in a bunch of amazing libraries
and cool projects like this one
um so in this talk we're gonna go
through Vincent nye's personal friends
page project
a project we came up with to provide
daily updates of new things going on on
topics that you in particular are
interested in so first we'll talk about
our annotation experience with this
project getting the data and creating a
custom Prodigy recipe to make annotating
the data set easier
and then we'll go into building the
spacing models and how that all worked
and finally we'll end up how you can
build your own personal front page and
I'll go through through some future
project plans and final thoughts at the
end since this is still kind of a work
in progress
I'm going to use our process of building
this project to talk about some of the
cool things that Spacey and Prodigy do
that I think are super interesting and
impactful for the developer experience
before we get into the project I just
want to quickly introduce Space theme
Prodigy for those who aren't familiar
with the libraries so Spacey is a
natural language processing python
Library as I mentioned we provide
pre-trained models and also pipeline
building blocks to do all sorts of
natural language processing related
tasks like ner text categorization and a
bunch of linguistic stuff as well
so you can train your own models on your
own data using Spacey or you can also
use their pre-trained models as well to
do projects and build applicational NLP
Pipelines
so you can assemble your natural
language processing Pipeline with a
specific components you want and that's
because space c is built using a modular
architecture
so you can put in the components that
make sense for your project without
having any unnecessary steps or
functionalities in the left box of the
slide here we have an excerpt from our
config file which is the building block
of species
modular pipeline architecture so by
updating the config you can easily swap
out some components for others but we
also provide defaults for everything so
you can use the out-of-box solution to
easily get started and then either
iterate as you go and I'll go into more
of this in the species section of the
talk
so moving on to Prodigy you can see a
screenshot from our online demo here and
as I mentioned Prodigy is an annotation
tool but what makes it cool is like
Spacey it also provides the ability for
extensive customizability while also
maintaining sensible default Solutions
you'll see this is kind of a theme in
this talk we provide a lot of different
recipes for annotation out of the box
like ner text categorization relation
instruction and a ton more
however as I'll show you with the front
page projects Prodigy is also super easy
to customize using your own python
functions I mean you can do things like
add custom HTML create functions that
run before you save data data to the
database or add help text
um like annotation guidelines directly
to the interface
and so now the project the project takes
data from archive which is if you're not
familiar with what that is it's a
website with a ton of academic papers on
different topics
when Vincent initially came up with the
idea for this project he noticed that
queries on archive wouldn't necessarily
give him the information he wanted so
for example if you were looking for
papers about new data sets searching for
data sets sometimes gives you methods
for data extraction or evaluation
metrics or other unrelated papers
so this got us thinking what if we could
create a machine learning solution to
find these papers related to say new
data sets and then also display these in
a daily updated web page we could then
keep up with new things happening and in
theory have different topics and
different sources to kind of create your
personalized front page
without having to rely on things like
Twitter
so we've created this project in a way
that you can update it with your own
data train your own models and topics
that you want to see on your front page
and we'll go through this in the third
section of this talk we do plan on
spanning this project more with topics
and new features soon but I'll walk you
through kind of the current status of
the project in a bit
so with that let's start on the first
part of the projects the data annotation
so as I mentioned we're using the
archive Pi Pi Library which is connects
to the archive API to pull papers
um directly from archive itself
so we're using a search query you can
see that at the top here we're searching
the title for data sets Corpus or
database or the abstract for the string
in your data set
we're then taking all the results and
putting it in a jsonnl file with the
title the description which is the
abstracts and tags which we have here
archive and data set
and also a meta tag which just has a
search query in it
this will allow us to do text
classification on the data using the
tags
and yeah so this is the data set class
which will be our main example for today
so when we started annotating this data
set we noticed that it was taking a lot
of time to skim the abstracts and find
the part where it says it was actually
about a new data set
the abstract can be kind of long and the
title of the paper can sometimes be
misleading so I found that you did
actually need to go through the entire
abstract to figure out whether it was
about a new data set or not so this got
us thinking always a good question is
there a way to do this better
so we decided to speed up the process by
using spacing matter patterns and you
can see an example of our data set
matchup pattern at the bottom screen
there
So within the abstract there is usually
a single or a couple sentences that said
something like we introduce a new data
set about blah or we introduce the RGB
Arabic alphabet sign language data site
and this was common across a lot of
examples so by
using the spacing Master patterns we
were able to highlight these and match
these examples where it said this
um and then we could put this in The
annotation interface more easily skim
the abstracts and have more consistent
results with The annotation and also
easier annotation process
so we implemented this using a spacing
matchup component and I'm just going to
go in a little bit of a tangent here I'm
a big proponent of including rule-based
solutions to enhance your machine
learning Pipeline and including rules to
make your data annotation better is
definitely a great way to do this so
building rules means you have to
understand the data you're working with
directly right and in my mind this is
essential to machine learning projects
I talked about a lot this in a recent
blog post I worked on in a project where
I combined rules with machine learning
to create a better pipeline from
everything from the data quality to the
evaluation scores
when we're building machine learning
pipelines I think this is something we
forget a lot it's really important to
understand every single part of the
process
and that definitely includes your data
and by because writing rules allows
really requires you to understand what's
being fed into your machine learning
models in your entire project it's a
great way to ensure consistency lay a
good foundation and ensure quality
in this project we use rules to ensure
annotation consistency by making it
easier for annotators to catch things
that they might otherwise have missed
so we're able to iterate our rules
create an iterative pipeline workflow
instead of a linear one as we gain more
experience with our data
and in turn this makes our whole
pipeline process better
so in order to provide this highlight
matching features and others we made our
own custom Prodigy text categorization
recipe when I first started this project
I hadn't really worked with custom
Prodigy recipes before and it really
really amazed me how simple it was to
get started with one and then keep
building upon it to customize it further
so this is what our recipe looks like
currently
you can see here we've in our box we
have custom HTML and this makes the
title bigger
and then we also have highlighted the
match patterns within the abstract just
by using the Highlight tag with an HTML
and the Bold tag as well
we're also displaying the link with HTML
at the bottom in case the annotator
needs to see the paper in full to make a
further decision which I have found is
really helpful in some cases
So within the custom Prodigy recipes you
can also Implement sorters within this
recipe we set a flag that when it's set
as true it will prefer entries with a
matched pattern and this allows us to
make to annotate more examples that are
relevant for our project and the
utilized matcher to make the process
either easier and better
as you mentioned as you may have saw in
a few slides ago we also provided a meta
tag within the data itself to provide
the search query for archive and this
just provides more transparency for the
annotator as well
all of this is done through a python
function so you can write it yourself
include it in your project and it's
super simple we provide examples and
descriptions of this all in our Prodigy
docs and always go to our support if you
need any help with this we're always
around
so for our data annotation we definitely
could have used a lot of solutions out
of the box for text classification right
it's not a very complicated problem
you're just saying whether it is or is
not
however because Prodigy provides
provided us with the tools to make
customizations easily we were able to
create a good annotation experience one
that made it easier for us to go through
examples and annotate them correctly and
consistently
we Market Prodigy as a scriptable
annotation tool and interface we have
the power to make adjustments that fit
to your project and what we've done with
this front page project is just a small
piece of what's actually possible
we've recently done a couple blog posts
about companies like the guardian who
have custom-made Prodigy super
extensively and powerfully
in this diagram you can see all the
customizations that the guardian did to
their annotation interface
we have quite a few here I think a
through H the annotators were able to or
that they were able to place their
annotation guidelines directly within
the Prodigy interface if you can see
they're a
so the annotators could review them if
they were ever confused on how to
annotate something without needing to
leave the web browser
um they also customize colors and theme
remove buttons and add custom labels
they add a custom flagging components
where an example could be flagged for
further review and also a feedback Bots
where the annotator could leave
descriptions or questions on the example
as well
this leads me to the first point I'd
really like to emphasize by putting
power in the hands of the developer
Prodigy enhances your experience
customizable Solutions enhance the
developer experience
so before I start talking about how we
train the model and all this awesome
data we now have
um I'll introduce the power behind
species models the config system
we introduced the config system in the
version 3 releases Spacey and the
solution to balancing ease of use with
customizability really really amazes me
the config file can sometimes look a
little scary especially if you're new to
development which it was for me for sure
but I promise it's not as scary as it
looks and once you understand the
mechanisms behind it you'll realize that
it's incredibly powerful and helpful in
the model building and training process
basically there's a config file for each
pipeline you build within Spacey the
file has all the settings for your
pipeline and each component individually
none of it hidden behind any abstraction
layers everything is there in the config
by default everyone everything is
visible with reasonable default values
as well
this means though that because
everything is in that one file you can
change settings in your pipeline simply
by swapping outlines in your config
for example here's an excerpt from our
test cat multi-label config right now
it's using all the default settings like
the Spacey tokenizer and the multi-label
Schooler for textcat
however if you wanted to swap out let's
say the score for your own custom
solution you simply change that line in
the config you register it within the
registry in your python file and that's
it you train your model
um
to start off we have a training quick
start guide that will generate a default
config with all your recommended
settings so for this project we're using
all the default settings to start so our
config is exactly how it's generated by
the Quick Start
as I mentioned though if we ever need to
change anything going forward this is
super easy to adjust for any further
Solutions we might need within this
project
training a spacing model again is super
easy with the Gen like the the general
settings with the space you train
command we simply pass in our config
that we generated pass the train and
test sets and output location and then
we wait for our model we can then load
this directly from the source with
Spacey load in our python file
um
so for this project we're using the test
cap multilabel spacing model
for this we give it labeled data with
categories so you saw earlier the data
set and we also have another one prompt
engineering on archive which we're using
as well
um so these two categories are for the
model and we take them text Cat model
and the textile model will assign new
data and assign predictions for both
categories including it in the correct
place on the front page or excluding it
if it's determined determines it's not
one of those categories so you can see
here the where data set um is seen to be
a data set our threshold is 0.5 for this
project so 0.75 definitely passes or
seven nine definitely passes prompt
engineering does not pass for this data
set it's 0.2 so that will be executed
out of the prompt engineering section
but included in the data set section
um
right and so for The Prodigy section I
talked a lot about customizability and
the power that brings in the hands of
the developer
in the space section this talk
I kind of went on the other end of the
spectrum we're using the out of the box
Solutions here right we're using the
defaults in the pre-configured building
blocks and that makes it super easy to
hit the ground running no customizations
are needed we're just using the
solutions
and this is also super important having
default solutions to things means it's
easy to get started and try things out
without the overhead of putting a having
to put a ton of effort in to get things
set up
as important as customizability is so is
not being overwhelmed with options and
having these default values as a
starting point
to build your project off of
so in order to make this a complete and
reproducible project we're using Spacey
project system
and I know I'm a bit biased but I really
really love the system it makes it super
easy to create and share projects and
tutorials and I don't have too much time
to go into this right now but I'm just
going to give you a little taste and
then you can go to the docs and look at
this more
at the heart of the project system is
the project diamo file here you'll find
information on commands project
structure and workflows and we're
definitely utilizing a lot this a lot in
our front page project so in the front
page projects at emo we have all the
commands for downloading data
pre-processing it annotating IT training
a model combining the output and then
building the front page
this would be a lot to normally remember
if you had to do all this by scratch so
we've set up a simple workflow that you
can simply just have to run Spacey
project run new front page
and it does it all for you which is
amazing and behind the scenes this is an
excerpt from the project yaml for the
download commands and you can see that
it's just running a command in The Bash
Bash terminal that's using our scripts
function and processing and arguments
so how can you create your own custom
front page
um well the first step is to find the
GitHub repo I have put the link here
then you can find your personal front
page config under the config folder and
I have that in the lower right left left
hand corner there
um so here you can set section topics
set settings change the change of the
description
um right now we're experimenting with
two topics data sets on archived and
prompt engineering on archives you can
see all the settings for those there
so this is kind of the mechanism behind
building the front page with your own
custom settings and hopefully we'll be
able to expand this soon with some more
topic changing functionality
um
as for the deployment of the front page
we're using GitHub pages to
automatically download data new day
every day and then update the page
so by changing the download command in
the project.yaml let's PC project
project.yaml you can then adjust the
project and the source and hopefully
again I'll make this easier and put this
all in the config file for the front
page but
future plans so once the data is
downloaded GitHub pages will also
automatically pre-process train a new
model generate the content stream with
the model and data and then populate the
front page this sounds like a lot but
it's actually just running Spacey
project run new front page GitHub behind
the scenes so again this BC project
system has really made it nice to
incorporate all these commands and run
them reproducibly automatically every
day
um
so basically if you want to customize
your front page you simply need to
annotate some data on a topic that you
want adjust the tags adjust the settings
and yeah that's it for now you can
definitely check out the GitHub repo
stay updated with new things coming we
have a lot of plans you can also deploy
visit the deployment page for my front
page this is kind of what it looks like
right now so when you click on one of
those one of the papers it come pops
down with the box it has the
um the classes the abstract and a link
to the paper
so it definitely works right now which
is pretty cool
so as I mentioned this project is still
a bit of a work in progress I'm super
excited to continue working with Vincent
on this we have a ton of plans including
make it easier to change topics upload
your own data and customize different
parts of the pipeline I will be working
on a better evaluation system next as
well as reconfiguring some of the
configs to make it easier to set up your
own topics
up next I thought I'd mention Vincent is
working on a super cool text
classification trick so in a nutshell we
decided that doing test classification
on the entire abstract was maybe an
approach that could be improved a bit
um so he'll be experimenting with
breaking the abstract up into sentences
and then doing text classification on
the individual sentences so if you
remember from the matcher patterns there
was usually just one or two sentences
that really made or break the text
classification and if we can find this
there may be a way to be more efficient
and also accurate with our predictions
so hopefully he'll give a talk soon with
some of his thoughts on the process so
definitely look out for that
um and then also for future plans we
we're thinking about supporting uh
spacing matcher instead of a spacing
model so you could use this without
having to annotate your own data and
just set matcha patterns instead of
training your own model also more
built-in models as well
and then we also want to do an A B
Prodigy classification interface so that
it can kind of learn what your interests
are so you can say yes I like this more
than this one and then it will learn
what your interests are as well and be
able to give you more tailored Solutions
or tailored papers
okay so Spacey was one of the first
libraries I ever used when I was just
starting out with python and knew
basically nothing I started with the
defaults using simply the built-in
components and as I've learned more and
grown my skills as a developer Spacey
has allowed me to expand and make more
complicated projects with custom
components
and to same with Prodigy when I started
with explosion I experimented with the
built-in recipes editing data when my
needs to expand for different projects I
was able to dive deeper into the product
and utilize different capabilities that
ultimately made my project better and
enhanced my experience as a developer
this spectrum is I think really hard to
balance in developer tooling but I also
think it's something that can be super
impactful if it's done right
on one hand you have to make it easier
to get started so the users have don't
have to put a ton of time into trying up
the solution you have to have ease of
use pre-configured building blocks and
good defaults
and then on the other hand you have to
make the library adaptable and
configurable so it can grow with the
development needs of a project you need
to have it compatible with Advanced
workflows for modern LP and machine
learning
space and Prodigy I think are both
really able to do this and it amazes me
every time I work with them and I know
I'm a bit biased but this is by far my
favorite feature of the developer tools
and I'm always so excited when I see
this in other places as well
adapter tooling doesn't have to be
complex to start and built-in components
don't have to remain stagnant giving
power to the developer to make decisions
to customize the project in pipelines I
believe ultimately results in a more
robust Solutions and a better
development experience
again thanks so much for joining me
today it's been a pleasure to rant about
things that make me excited I think we
have some time for questions but you can
also find me around the conference or at
these various links to going forward
thank you
thank you so much Victoria that was a
very fascinating talk well done we have
a few questions on slido
um so Sebastian wants to know do you
think the project would scale to generic
news aggregation
um
that's a good question I think generic
news might be a little hard we do have
plans for like Hacker News and Reddit
Integrations
um I think the main part would be the
scraping and like the API for like
generic news and I I don't know if
that's something we're necessarily
interested in building which might
influence that as well so yeah yeah
would be cool though it would be cool
someone please iterate over that
um Sebastian also had a question that I
would have asked myself as well can you
give us a live demo of your front page
yes I can
uh
Maybe
yes there it is
nice so this is the front page project
um you can see here we have data sets on
archive and then prompt engineering
archive so we can just look at some
examples here let's see a data set for
exploring dependency relations between
events so you can see here text
classification model is still not doing
really well this is definitely a room
for like Improvement that we want it's
like giving 0.55 accuracy to this even
though it seems like it's
is about a data set in front engineering
we don't have enough data for this yet
so it still needs to improve a bit but
yeah so and then you can go to link
and yeah
that's that cool as a former academic I
would have killed to have a front page
like this to be honest okay
so I know uh it's still late for me
um it's not too late for you
um okay next question is it possible to
use third-party models or algorithms for
data classification for example hugging
phase Transformers or even sell for
um we can definitely build this
functionality into the project we don't
have it yet in there because it's pretty
tied to building a spacing model in the
but you could definitely change just the
workflow in the Spacey project system to
include your
other model besides the spacing model
and it would work perfectly fine so this
um the way we built this is very modular
so you can definitely swap out and swap
in different parts of the pipeline cool
next question is topic modeling
something that you considered for the
front page the papers might fit together
in various ways thanks for the great
talk
topic modeling yeah I mean
I think definitely
um
yes
we will see right
uh yeah but fits the scope pretty well
yeah it does yeah so um someone was just
asking where we can find slides to your
top
I will post them so if you go to
um explosion
Dash events you can see all our events
and once I have them downloaded I will
post them right here okay great yeah
um does anyone in the room have
questions
just raise your hand and I'll bring over
the mic to you
we're keen
um going once okay there you go
in the config file you specify that the
language is English
um
is it possible to
predict the language of text when you
have a bunch of text you don't know the
language
they are going to be in yeah I mean um
you could definitely do that with
another Spacey model and just include
that in your project pipeline but you
wouldn't be able to do it out of the box
with this solution right now I think
most of the papers on archive are in
English so I think we have her using an
English Spacey model for those papers
and it just would not work for a project
I wasn't in or for a paper that wasn't
in English
but you could definitely do it with
other facing models right
any other questions
okay going once
going twice
okay thank you so much Victoria thank
you so much it's been a fantastic talk